joining me this week is a writer with
the International Business Times in the
editor of their political capital
section which explores the intersection
of money in politics he's also one of
the few people in media who consistently
calls out both sides David Sirota
welcome to the Rubin report thanks so
much for having me I appreciate it
yeah well this is long overdue I've been
harassing you for a while and let's talk
about that intersection of money in
politics cuz that pretty much is what
it's all about right like at the end of
the day everything comes back to that
everything comes back to money in
politics I mean you can explain I mean I
think you can explain much of of the
elections and and and not just the
election outcomes but what different
stakeholders and the elections really
want and what the candidates really
represent by looking at the money I mean
it's the oldest most you know kind of
old-fashioned notion of journalism
follow the money and there's plenty of
money to be followed and certainly in
this race and and I would say you know
even beyond the presidential race the
the congressional races state races
gubernatorial races I mean there's just
so much money being spent right now and
money is not spent in politics for for
for altruistic reasons for the most part
I mean you've got for instance a billion
dollars in this election cycle being
spent on state and local races that is
not money typically a lot of that money
is not money being spent altruistically
that is that is money that is being
spent more like an investment yeah so
what is the actual connection between
money and action because this is one of
the things when when Bernie and Hillary
were going at each other
her defense kept being well you got to
prove that yes I'm taking money from
people she's not denying it
but you got to prove that it's made me
do anything and I don't know that he
ever quite made the connection how do
you as someone that that writes about
this stuff how do you actually figure
out if someone said oh well I took this
money how do you actually prove that the
action was cuz of that well you know
it's it's rare that you get a piece of
evidence that that explicitly proves a
so-called quid pro quo
politicians are pretty smart about that
you know I mean there's a there's for
instance an SEC pay-to-play rule which
says in general that financial firms
that are contracted to manage state
pension funds retiree money they can't
give money or at least the goal of the
rule is that they can't give campaign
contributions to governor's who have the
power to make those investment decisions
and the reason I bring up that rule is
because in the write up of that rule in
the SEC created that rule they
essentially said in the preamble of the
rule that there's no way in many cases
to to concretely prove a do a quid pro
quo but we know that money nonetheless
influences policy in that case in
investment decisions and it influences
it in all sorts of of explicit and
implicit ways when you are for instance
surrounded by the donor class at all
times as as a lawmaker and your world is
disproportionately a world of fund
raising and getting big money from
politically connected industries and
executives that's naturally going to
skew your policy views both I think
through the process of osmosis where
these are the only people that you're
hearing from and also through a process
of understanding what kinds of resources
you need to run a campaign so that's one
way where money is influencing in a very
deep way policy and the political debate
where there may not be the standard
envelope stuffed with cash in exchange
for you know with a note that says I
want you to vote this way right I mean
that's typically not how it works and
again at the SEC and their rule they
acknowledge that and so I I in in some
ways I reject the the the Clinton
campaigns argument which was basically
the argument was no that if there's no
evidence of a quid pro quo everything's
fine I just simply reject that I mean
first and foremost it may it's things
that may be legal technically legal are
still newsworthy important and at times
ethically questionable so this idea that
if something is League
it's not even newsworthy we shouldn't
even be talking about it I mean that's
that's completely ridiculous you know I
would also say that this this notion of
meaning proof of a quid pro quo to prove
corruption I also think is is in many
cases nonsense if we understand and are
honest about how money in politics works
we understand that you know these
industries you know Wall Street let's
say is not giving millions of dollars to
political candidates out of the goodness
of you know JP Morgan's heart I'm not
giving money as an investment and they
expect to return on their investment and
and we can go through examples whether
it's Donald Trump whether it's Hillary
Clinton Republicans Democrats there are
clear examples where money goes in from
a particular industry and a policy
position or a policy favor comes out now
I don't subscribe to the idea that
that's not potentially problematic if
there was no envelope of cash with the
note that says that's exactly what I
want it's problematic and it's I would
argue in it's typically not coincidental
that the money went in and the policy
came out or the policy went out and then
the money came in those are typically
not coincidental things I mean was
Barney Frank who was you know the top
ally of Hillary Clinton he said a couple
years ago on on NPR and I'm paraphrasing
here but he said you know this is this
idea that money doesn't influence policy
unless there's an explicit quid pro quo
we'd be the first people in the history
in human history where money didn't
influence decisions and didn't influence
human behavior so this idea that the
connection between actions and donations
are are are all coincidences unless you
have explicit quick quid pro quo I think
it's kind of ridiculous right so is the
best example of that sort of the Hillary
situation with Wall Street because
basically we know that you know Goldman
Sachs and these companies they were
paying her for speeches she got a lot of
money from Wall Street and then once the
speeches were exposed she basically said
in these speeches well you guys are the
experts so you guys should regulate
themselves so it wasn't that there was
some sort of thing that she necessarily
signed because the money she got but
it's just the general implication more
than anything else which had there not
been money why would she have said it
all right well I mean I also think it's
what perspective are you coming at
issues from if you're coming in issues
from a Wall Street perspective not even
making a value judgment on that that's
just your perspective you're gonna have
a different set of views potentially
than somebody who's coming from a labor
perspective of a union perspective and
so I think that as it relates to Hillary
Clinton and Wall Street money look I
think that look some of the Wall Street
money she's gotten as the Wall Street is
concerned like stability I mean that's
just a general kind of non partisan taya
likes the status quo like stability
Donald Trump represents instability
unpredictability hillary clinton
represents what is perceived to be
predictability so i think there's that
some of it but but I also think look
she's somebody who has been very
friendly with Wall Street throughout her
career and there's instances where she's
certainly helped Wall Street and she
talked about that policy-wise in her
speeches to Wall Street I think going
above the specific policies that and
votes that she's cast and you know the
bank bailouts and the like that that
she's supported mm-hmm I think there's
also money engenders a perspective that
the and it goes to back to this you know
arguably less explicit but I would say
in some cases more powerful form of
influence where if you're surrounded by
Wall Street if you were campaigns rely
on Wall Street funding if Wall Street is
your world it will be a bigger part of
your starting point perspective on
issues when you get into a public office
and that more than anything can be the
most powerful form of influence because
here's the thing if you're looking at a
policy decision and you've already
started at a perspective where you're
ruling out XY and Z and you're ruling in
only a B and C the Wall Street a B and C
then
Wall Street didn't even have to fight on
X Y & Z because they have changed the
course of the conversation the
parameters of the conversation the
parameters of the policy debate with the
key lawmakers who set the agenda how
much of this do you sort of put the
blame of our current state on Obama
because even this week I was seeing he's
fundraising for Hillary at private
events in California we know these are
$30,000 of plate dinners I mean he's
he's at the end of his presidency you
know it was all about hope and change if
anything to me in the eight years
although he obviously has done some good
stuff the system got got more ingrained
money got more ingrained in the system
in these last eight years when really
that could have been and maybe should
have been his biggest less legacy that
we really were gonna change in the
system but it only could have been done
by money so what does it say that a
two-term outgoing president still right
now is spending so much time raising
money for the party well I mean I'm sure
that President Obama and his aides
justified as kind of ends justify the
means or as they might they might put in
a nicer way they're not gonna quote
unilaterally disarm in helping the party
when it comes to money in politics and
then I think they use that phrase right
haven't they use that really yeah it's
just it's just it's a standard phrase
right that's it I mean I may not like
the the system but I have to operate in
it you know don't hate the player hit
the game that kind of thing you know but
I think where that argument falls apart
especially on the Democratic side is in
Bernie Sanders is fundraising Bert and I
don't think this has been talked about
enough which is to say that Bernie
Sanders fundraising juggernaut in the
primary was seen as amazing unexpected
but the deeper analysis I think is it
kind of blows away the entire argument
that you can't run a well financed
campaign without using the standard big
money corporate fundraising tactics
Bernie Sanders didn't win not because he
didn't raise enough money Bernie Sanders
didn't win for lots of other reasons
but it wasn't a resource question and
and if it was a resource question I mean
I've heard the argument that while he
was only able to raise money sort of too
late in the game and he wasn't able to
front load the money raising with big
money but I don't think anybody argues
that the fundamental reason Bernie
Sanders lost was because he didn't have
enough resources and so that blows away
the idea that Democratic candidates or
the right Democratic candidates or
progressive Democratic candidates it's
impossible for them to run a well
financed campaign without using big
money sources now I I will you know
there's an asterisk there which is that
look presidential politics tends to
dominate all the bit you know the entire
debate in a way I would argue that had
has not been the case even in the lab
you know move in ten years ago I it was
it was dominant but it wasn't as
dominant I feel like now when Americans
think of politics they think the
presidential race and that is basically
it everything else is it is a
down-ballot race so I think it's
difficult for potentially a candidate
for Congress or even you know a state
representative state Senate to raise
serious money through small dollar
sources because they simply don't have
the platform that a presidential
candidate has and a president and the
presidential campaign kind of drowns out
down ballot races but I do think that
that that there is there is an
encouraging path there which is to say
that there can be at least more of a mix
of small dollar and some big dollar
donations that the old fundraising model
of simply get you know ten people in a
room to give you the twenty five or
fifty thousand dollars and that's how
politics is going to work there is I
think now an alternate path and and I
want to add that I think that that the
reason that hasn't been talked about the
reason the the Sanders example hasn't
been more talked about in the context of
that is because it's threatening it's
threatening to the to the interest that
that control politics right now
yuras a u.s. senator right now and
you've gotten elected using the old
fundraising model a kind of big money
corporate fundraising model uh you're
pretty happy with this it yours you know
one a small dollar fundraising apparatus
to to occur because that may finance
your primary challenger or your general
election challenger
so there are vested political interests
who don't want what happened in the
Sanders campaign to be talked about who
don't want there to be that alternative
pathway because the people who are
elected officials now are basically
masters of the current existing universe
so they in particular have a vested
interest in not changing that universe
because they're the masters right now so
all that being said and I'm totally with
you what should we how should Bernie
feel right now because it seems to me
that a lot of the progressives
especially the Millennials are simply
not gonna vote for Hillary I think you
know they they don't like the money
stuff the Wall Street stuff all of that
and now Bernie I think sort of looks
like a sellout because he's backing the
the number one ingrained political
institution person in Hillary you know
he got the house on the lake in Vermont
and it's sort of like in a way it's
almost like she kind of killed the
movement and we know that the DNC was
working with her to do it because then
debbie Wasserman Schultz had to step
down and of course what did she do she
went to work for Hillary Clinton so what
do you make of the state of the Bernie
revolution well I don't think we can
judge it yet I mean I think it I think I
think right after the election and into
the first few months is where the rubber
is really going to hit the road and the
sense of whether or not the revolution
or political movement that he galvanized
is really going to be serious
III doesn't it kind of feel over already
I guess that's my point more than it
does it sort of fuels arel like there it
was there no doubt it was there whether
you liked it or not but it's see it
feels irrelevant to me at this point and
I don't know why she would feel if she
was president at this point she got what
she needed out of him already he helped
her get there so why would she oh
well look III don't think it's about
Owen I guess that's that's what I'm
trying to say which I don't think it I
don't think the Clinton machine feels
any sense of loyalty or or owing to to
the movement that Sanders galvanized and
III think it's it's more a question of
our political leaders like Bernie
Sanders Elizabeth Warren going to use
the independent platforms that they have
to be confrontational with a White House
that will be headed by somebody who has
proven time and again she is not a
steadfast ally of the progressive movie
I mean she's taken progressive positions
at certain points in her career but this
is not somebody who is a what you might
call a conviction politician I don't
think it's controversial to say that so
the question is will the political
movement be confrontational and at times
be willing to be adversarial with a
Democratic Party's white house with a
Democrat in office who it's crystal
clear is not a conviction politician and
I think the jury's out on that but I but
I you know I can argue it either way
yeah I mean here's the thing the the
progressive movement the modern
progressive movement does not have a
good track record of being willing to in
any kind of serious way
hold Democratic Party politicians feet
to the fire once those those politicians
are in office Barack Obama is I think
example number one I mean he comes into
office making all sorts of promises you
know the anti-war movement basically you
know for all intents and purposes the
mass anti-war movement kind of faded
away the the the the core criticism of
Wall Street was kind of anesthetized by
Obama you saw some of it it bubbled up
at times but there was not you know
there were not mass there was not mass
pressure on Obama when he took positions
that were oppositional to the
progressive movement I think you've seen
a little bit of that on TPP so you know
it's not it's not all 100
like there's nothing but you know the
the so that's one way to argue and say
you know the the this is not nothing's
gonna happen after the elections gonna
be the same old but I think the other
way the other way you can look at it and
I don't know which way it's gonna go
is that Hillary will Clinton will come
in as the most unpopular first term
president in modern history
III think the polls show that I mean
what does it have for three quarters of
her voters are going to be voters who
are primarily motivated by voting
against Donald Trump so I think you know
in in you could argue that that that
creates a dynamic that might actually be
productive so that the popular
president's popular Democratic
presidents who come into office get the
benefit of the doubt to basically sell
out to their corporate donors and maybe
it's a good thing if a Democratic
president comes in disliked or held in
suspicion by a large mass of voters and
that creates a tension where the
progressive movement it feels like it
can be adversarial and confrontational
and that the Clinton White House feels
like it it it not that it wants to
respond not that it o is a response but
that it has to respond for all sorts of
various political reasons in a situation
where the where the the new president
isn't all that popular yeah I hope it's
the latter but I tend to think it's
gonna be the former but we shall see all
right so let's move over to the
Republicans because the Republican
situation with money especially related
to presidential politics is particularly
weird at the moment now as someone that
I say every week on the show I don't
believe anything that Donald Trump says
do we actually know how much money he's
put in and what is really going on with
the fundraising
I checked his site yesterday I mean
they're obviously taking donations and
you know he is doing some fundraisers
but is any of that transparent I mean
it's really hard to know who Donald
Trump thinks he owes I guess who his we
know that he's gotten some hedge fund
money and he's gotten you know some some
developer money you know i Donald Trump
is it's it's hard to analyze him through
the prism of money in politics
because he has been a a kind of media
creation I mean I do think the the other
you know we talked about Bernie Sanders
a small dollar fundraising you know
Donald Trump is a a different kind of
resource juggernaut in the sense that he
didn't really have to spend that much
money because he was such a free media
phenomenon you know and and he says he
has his own money and and and he spent
some of his own money on that but look I
to me Trump I mean he hasn't been
successful at least if they believe the
polls but but he's been successful in
sort of the larger sense of me is the
Republican nominee he'll probably get
above 40% of the country voting for him
and he and I think arguably he could
have done that with by spending almost
no money because he is so so well known
so famous so iconoclastic and so I think
moving forward you know Trump opens up
this possibility that that we've all
kind of kicked around in our mind I
think of of what I've heard somebody
called the Q score president right Q
score is the I think is cute right the Q
School is like how famous are you it's
sort of raining for celebrities and how
famous are you and they have this
aggregate way of figuring that out and
it's kind of like Donald Trump ran on
basically pure Fame and name recognition
and celebrity and then you know mixed in
some you know very controversial
positions but it opens up the
possibility of what's next is is you
know you're gonna have like Tom Hanks
run for president
Harrison Ford or just people who are
just purely fit and as I take take away
from those actors but people who are
just purely famous who can just
transition very quickly to becoming
political figures and we had that with
Ronald Reagan although I think that's
misremembered I mean Ronald Reagan was
kind of a b-movie actor he was he was
well known but certainly not as famous I
don't think as Donald Trump when Trump
ran but you know he's ever heard before
he was also a good point right now but
also a political experience but we but
it's it's kind of a
amazing to think about that look the
next election I mean I throw it out
there think about the most famous actor
you can I mean if George Clooney decided
to run for president of the United
States in an open C election would you
say that he didn't have a chance to
become the Democratic nominee for
president I'd say you know he'd have a
pretty a pretty decent shot I mean yeah
you know rally would things being equal
so I so is that good or bad it it's hard
to know because because I think the the
argument I've heard that you know the
argument is that well it's not that
great that you have to come up through
this political machine and you become a
you know House member than a senator
that you have a president and that has
all sorts of corrupting problems also
but I think Trump we've seen now the the
flip side of that which is that if you
have somebody who's running basically
purely on controversial positions plus Q
score that's not all that great either
even if that person isn't tied to the
political machine and to the end to them
to the moneyed establishment that runs
politics I mean Donald Trump is part of
the money to establishment generally but
he's not really tied to the to the
political money machine yeah is there a
chance that some of us on the Left are
not giving Trump enough credit in that
this is a guy who has done made a lot of
money for him and we regardless of how
much money he actually has and
whatever's going on with bankruptcies
and taxes and all that this is a guy
who's lived in a lot of money with you
know and has helped his family and built
these companies and all those things and
he is actually trying to change the
system now we could go back and forth on
whether that would be good or not but
our it seems to me that some of us on
the Left were being a little too
dismissive of maybe he's trying to like
you're basically saying he is sort of
extricate ourselves from this corrupt
system maybe it's not for good reasons
and maybe just running on Q scores no
good and all that but that there might
be something good here you know sort of
getting away from all the fringe parts
about his personality and over-the-top
statements and that kind of thing well
look III take the view I view it this
way that Donald Trump is a is a complete
opportunist that's what he is he's
opportunism the personification of
opportunism by the way I think Hillary
Clinton is
personification of opportunism in a
different in a different way I think
they both have different formulas or see
different opportunities and Trump has
created a scene and created
opportunities for himself in ways that
are pretty are pretty ugly are pretty
dangerous are pretty really appealing to
people's worst instincts but I just look
at it this way that you separate out
Donald Trump from what he's done which i
think is important to do if you look at
Trump as a political phenomenon even
separating out all the really serious
issues about you know bigotry and and
and polarization and demonizing
minorities you separate all that out and
you ask what does Donald Trump represent
as a political phenomenon beyond his
specific the the specific beliefs he
happens to be espousing and I think it
is did a dissatisfaction with politics
as usual a dissatisfaction with with
what we call the establishment of both
parties and I think that while Trump may
we will likely flame out and not win the
presidency I think that he has awakened
people on both sides there their
recognition that the country is deeply
in a much more profound way than perhaps
we ever thought deeply disconnected from
and dissatisfied with its political
system with its frankly it's it's
economic system yeah and I think that
you know Trump may be the the the
Trailblazer in this sense that he kind
of blazes the trail or he's you know I
used the football metaphor you know he's
the he's the full-back who's going up
ahead the block for the halfback behind
them is carrying the ball that you may
have Trump flame out and Democrats cheer
and celebrate that and then four years
later a another Republican comes from
from you know behind Trump
where Trump has blazed a trail where
another Republican without all the
baggage of Trump manages to galvanize
some of the same thing that Trump has
galvanized and without the baggage of
Trump and becomes a very successful
politician I mean I think you know the
election that sticks with me when I
think about this election every election
is different people love to make
comparisons but if you're gonna make it
comparison I think you know 1964 when
you had you had LBJ was not a super
popular at that point president and
inherited presidency he was a democratic
polygamous scheen politician connected
to the establishment you know he exuded
kind of the the you know establishment
politics versus Barry Goldwater who was
this perceived as this outsider was
saying a lot about outrageous things and
goal one and and Johnson portrays
Goldwater is essentially insane Johnson
wins his big election mandate it seems
like this big realignment election
because it was one of the biggest
landslides in history and then four
years later there was Richard Nixon all
right the Republicans won now a lot of
stuff happened in those four years but
the point is that Trump I don't think
he's trying to serve a longer term
ideological interest but he may end up
effectively serving a longer term
ideological or at least partisan
interest for the Republicans in the
sense of of making it easier and and and
training of the parts of the electorate
to to to want and to reward people who
are anti-establishment politicians on
the right yeah that's interesting and I
don't even see that it's something that
would just be rewarding the Republicans
because if there was a real
anti-establishment feeling it could
reward the Democrats to to get some new
grassroots people up there well you
think so although there's you know the
the amazing thing I think right now is
that there is more anti-establishment
fervor inside the Republican Party and
generally on the right then there is
inside the Democratic Party and on the
left
I think that the oddly the American left
is a much more I think has become a much
more corporatized professionalized
political machine with all of the I
guess tactical success of that but a lot
of the loss of a principled protest and
on the right you have a transformation
of a Republican Party that used to be
feel a lot more you know
professionalized and and lockstep and
top-down has become in some ways the the
home of protest and dissent now now I
want to be clear I'm not making I'm not
saying it's good dissent I'm not saying
it's motivated out of something that's
that's honorable or or I'm and make no
value judgment I'm just saying as
political phenomena let's go you know
the the the left has has become very
good at suppressing I think protest and
dissent and being more of a political
machine and it's the right now that
where that protest and foment and
dissent exists and that's really a flip
from when you think about you know when
you think back to the to the 1960s in
the 1970s and which parties were the
parties or you know that harness dissent
and which parties did and did not yeah
and that so gets to why I talk about the
left so much because I want my side to
be better and I've seen the left
now look Obama is gonna leave office as
the longest president ever serving you
know while we were at war because it was
every single day of his presidency we
have the left now nominating and likely
will be the president will be the
biggest Wall Street money ever we have
the left now suddenly talking about war
with Russia or you know they they were
all about loving WikiLeaks and Assange
and Snowden and now the information that
we've gotten about that because it's
about Hillary suddenly they don't like
it anymore like I've really seen
something sort of terrible I think
happened to the left in the last couple
of years and I guess that's because
Obama has been in power and they felt
you know it's like how's Hillary in a
weird way it's like Hillary has to run
against Obama but at the same time has
to keep propping him up
yeah well I mean look there's a lot of
factors that are there a play I think I
mean I think that certainly on the
American Left party loyalty is a
stronger force than it is right now on
the right you see that I mean one of the
tell-tale signs is you look across you
know left-wing magazines left-wing
publications and it's all anti-trump all
pro-hillary all the time
there is almost no scrutiny of Clinton
on any kind of policy matter whatsoever
any kind of principled cause there's no
analysis of that so it really was the
greatest gift to the corporatists in a
way because then they could get the
eyeballs off Hillary right and just go
but yeah it's I mean is what I say Trump
Trump is the has been the glue that has
held the American Left together
for the last year or so and and but I
mean that's oversimplifying I mean I
think you know Republican Party extreme
ago it's Trump you know before with Ted
Cruz and you know they try to do that
with with Paul Ryan that's a little more
difficult only because of his kind of
public image but you know position wise
and I think that the left has really
used the right or being anti Republican
as its glue and it'll be interesting to
see if that can if if if what we're you
know loosely calling the American Left
can can can continue to have that glue
be it a cohesive force in a Clinton
presidency I've often wondered you know
what happens on November 9th and Clinton
is elected president and you can't just
scream Trump you can't just say the word
Trump to just end conversations about
issues like Wall Street regulation war
and peace defense spending
you know surveillance civil liberties I
mean right now and certainly the last
year so certainly after the primaries I
guess you know you you see a story
reported about a legitimate issue the
questions of money politics corruption
whatever it is it
energy policy about clinton and the
conversation ender whether it's online
in social media or an interpersonal
conversation the conversation editor is
well she better than Trump or just
simply Trump just scream the name Trump
yeah compensation is over yeah what
happens on November 9th when when you
can't just do that I mean my bet is that
you know the Democrats are already
thinking about that and then they'll say
you know Paul Ryan or they'll say Ted
Cruz right as effective those are not as
scary in the first two years of a
Clinton presidency when when there may
even be a Democratic Senate I you you'd
you'd like to believe that post-election
there will be a more honest discourse
and policy debate and I say that you
know again not making a value judgment
I'm a Democrat a Republican or liberal
or conservative but I think it would be
good for the country to have more of the
the policy debates actually be on the
merits rather than being tribal battles
between you know two competing parties
you